sixty-six teams from across the globe
and come to Zurich for a unique
competition in a true blending of man
and machine people with physical
disabilities are competing head-to-head
it's been dubbed the world's first
cyborg Olympics
the rules of the games are simple
roboticists neurologists and other
researchers are paired with disabled
competitors that have been robotically
enhanced races are based on different
disabilities the fastest time wins the
competitors are grouped as closely in
ability as possible to avoid unfair
competition the technology can be
conceptual or off the show it just has
to be safe the mission to improve
assistive technologies and to better
integrate those with disabilities in
everyday life
I've come to the Swiss arena to meet up
with the team from Imperial College
London
Kevin Edison has a cutting-edge robotic
arm after an industrial accident with a
three decades ago a computer programmer
his mechanical arm has dramatically
improved his life he's competing in the
arm prosthetics race where he'll have to
perform household chores like hanging
clothes and cutting bread twitching
muscle
you know I decide what level one what if
I wanted to Ristorante if that is
instant the university is using his
experience with the Bionic hand to
identify limitations of current
technology the team hopes to use this
info to develop and commercialize also
on the Imperial polish team is Johnny
beer Tim's
who broke his neck in a trampoline
accident when he was only 16 he can't
move his legs but by placing electrodes
on his skin he can pedal modified
bicycle at the end of the muscle the
same for the hamstrings and my glutes as
well and it comes out on these wires
here and then in this box here FES porks
fires the muscles in a sequence and
enables my legs to go round the electric
shock being pumped into Johnny's legs
with buckle you are me but he can't feel
it
the university is building a eye that
will monitor things like how tired his
legs get so I battle on is not just an
event to see who can run the fastest or
jump a high instead it's how Tech is
helping people with severe disabilities
to everyday tasks
Johnny blitz his qualifying racing is
through to the final he starts strong
and quickly falls behind his California
competitor has some of the most advanced
technology in the world Johnny comes in
second
but his coach Paul Moore couldn't be
happier a cordial might work you'd be
he's been with the side battle and
especially they are six months
exit
the research outside Babylon has broad
implications
scientists believe studying people with
severe handicaps we need to fill one
with the robots are even breakthroughs
in self-driving cars
there are no cash prizes for the winners
but that's not the point it's about
pushing the limits of science